[Music]
welcome to all of you my minimum goal
was to have at least one person here and
we seem to have over achieved that so so
that's fantastic tests from data
analysis the what I'm trying to do with
this is to make it very hands-on there
are exercises to do if you haven't
downloaded stuff already there are
points on the slides to doing it there
were some handouts which some people
have got but some people haven't but I
think there are points on the slides to
them they're all available online so
what I guess I'm planning to do is to
talk a little bit about what tests
driven data analysis is in case any of
you haven't haven't heard it yet which
might well be the case and then talk
through the two main ideas or the
two-and-a-half main ideas in it as it is
today and try and get you actually using
the TDD a library that's available both
on pi pierre pi PI
and on github if you prefer source you
are welcome to try that obviously on
your own data or there is test data
provided with the library that you can
work on and I've kind of assumed on the
slides that's what you're doing but
you're welcome to do whichever you want
do ask questions do dive in we don't
have an enormous amount of time but I
think it's more you know probably if you
haven't understood something someone
else won't have understood it as well so
it's probably much better that you that
you ask I suppose I should possibly just
give 30 seconds on myself which is I've
been doing data analysis for about 30
years now and I have a tiny data
analysis company based up in Edinburgh
which is lovely we do consulting and
software include so we have commercial
software which includes all this stuff
but obviously also the open source
library which I'm talking about today so
everything that I'm talking about today
is MIT license you can do it you can
contribute to it I'd love to get
feedback bugs pull requests
contributions any of that that kind of
stuff really hope you can use it and get
some value out of it
the slide incidentally there's a URL on
on the front there you can pick them up
if you want to
that'll appear a couple of times later
on as well TVA info is a blog that talks
about about all these ideas so so
test-driven data analysis it probably
won't surprise you the idea is to take
the ideas from test-driven development
which is the sort of common sense I
would say to all the agile approaches to
software development that aim to help
with software correctness and to take
those ideas and apply adapt them and
apply them to the area of data analysis
data analysis broadly any kind of data
transformation that you might be doing
and I guess the idea the thing that
makes it interesting is that whereas
with software you're primarily concerned
with correctness and we're certainly
interested in correctness with data
analysis as well I think with analysis
it's harder because as well as
correctness we need to be worried about
the meaningfulness of the analysis you
know are we are we correctly applying
meaningless algorithms or inapplicable
algorithms to our data we have to be
concerned with the correctness and
validity of our input data so it's you
know we're not really doing our jobs as
analysts I would say if we just say you
know you give me garbage up in I'm going
to give you garbage out we kind of have
to take responsibility for trying to
make sure as far as we can that things
look ok and perhaps most difficult of
all we also have to as far as we can
take some responsibility for the
correctness of interpretation at least
in the sense of making our outputs as
clear as possible making it as hard as
possible for people to misinterpret our
results if anyone here not familiar with
test-driven development has anyone not
heard of test-driven development onehand
okay so very briefly Testim development
is the idea about the historical
software development process basically
consisted of first of all writing a
specification for software and then
writing a design for software and then
writing the software and then at the end
of the process writing some tests
to try and make sure that the software
actually worked and test-driven
development is the idea that you turn
that round completely and before you
write any software you first of all
write tests for the software that say
what it ought to do so if you're writing
addition you know an addition function
you at least write some stuff that says
you know when you add two and three that
should produce five and when you add
three and minus three that should
produce zero and so forth and you you
write those tests before you write any
software and and you write them in a
runnable form there are frameworks out
there that allow you to write these
tests run them have them fail because
you haven't written the addition
function yet and then then when you when
you write the software to actually
implement that addition function
hopefully the tests pass or in practice
what really happens is you discover that
your tests are wrong and you modify them
and the idea with test-driven
development is that you keep running
these tests all the time on fixed sets
of data and possibly on variable sets of
data and this has turned out to be I
think a much better way of doing
software development much a productive
way of doing software development and
it's not something we're not so
concerned about the order of things here
but what we're concerned here with
trying to get the answer right with
right in the most general sense possible
meaningful answers answers that are
actually going to add value answers
they're actually going to be useful to
people so the diagram that I usually
used to illustrate this starts off with
almost all data analysis projects in my
experience start off looking something
like this there's some kind of a
development phase and in the old days it
used to be that that was pretty much the
only phase there was but typically
there's a deployment phase now as well
and you know during that development
phase we almost always use some kind of
initial sample of data to try and make
things work and I guess in thinking
about test driven data analysis what
we've been thinking about is what are
the things that can go wrong in this in
this process and the first thing that
can go wrong is when we choose our
approach we can we can fail to
understand the data we can fail to
understand the problem that
or we can fail to understand the methods
well enough that we're thinking about
using in solving the problem and if we
get any of those things wrong clearly
we're very I'd like to get our analysis
right and we've sort of come up with
this taxonomy of that whereby we call
these these different kinds of errors
different things so we call those errors
of interpretation where we fail to
understand something fundamental about
the problem right at the start and so
clearly we want to avoid these errors of
interpretation
having done that when we're developing
our analysis and I'm using the term
analysis very broadly it could be
building you know a self learning live
you know recommender system or credit
scoring system or something or it could
be you know summing the salary bill or
something's basically anything that
involves taking data and producing a
result that we would think of as any
kind of data analysis so the next part
is once we've decided what we want to do
algorithmically how we want to solve
this problem tackle this problem then we
have to implement that in some way and I
don't necessarily mean writing code per
se by this this might be you know
running our or SAS or it might be you
know typing things into Excel or it
might be using a GUI or it might be
actually developing Python code with
pandas and you know libraries and all
this or bouquet or whatever but whatever
it is there's there's there's you know
we go from the states where we haven't
got our analytical processing code to
the point where we can we can do our
analysis and and that's what I mean by
the development of the analytical
process and the bad news is that it's
possible to screw up there as well so
it's possible to make mistakes during
our I mean I'm calling it coding but in
the process of doing the first the first
actual instance of the analysis and just
because we like calling them all error
of something we call that an error of
implementation but there's a there's a
more familiar word for that that's just
a bug right in convention software terms
and in terms of our our sample data
pretty much if we get the approach right
if we choose good algorithms if we
understand our data and we implement it
correctly then hopefully we'll get some
initial success we'll go whatever it is
on our sample data will now be right
we'll have some Desalle arees correctly
or with a built a useful model
maybe not even a useful model but at
least a correct model in a model that's
doing what it's supposed to do and so
that's our that's our kind of initial
success and it used to be that that's
pretty much all there was to most
modeling but I don't like you but what I
find these days is that there's almost
always an operational phase as well so
whereas it used to be that as
consultants we would go in and we'd you
know we build a model someone we'd hand
it over we'd either hand over the scores
or we'd hand over the you know a
specification of the model and someone
else would then be responsible for
implementing it typically these days
there's now an operational phase it's
not enough just to build the model we
have to set the thing running make it so
that it can be used continuously to make
recommendations or to produce credit
scores or to figure out who's at risk of
churning or you know whatever it is and
very often there's a soft learning
process in there as well where the model
has to update itself or at very least a
monitoring process where you know it can
figure out whether it whether it seems
to be behaving correctly and the bad
news is that there are lots more
opportunities to get things wrong during
these phases as well so you know if
we've developed our analytical process
and now we want to feed a new dataset
through we want to you know credit score
a new person all we want to you know add
up this month salaries rather than last
month salaries or whatever we now have
to run it and it's possible to use that
I'm assuming we've captured this
analytical process in some way in
software and because we now have to feed
the data in it's possible to screw up
that part of it and it's maybe even more
likely that we'll screw it up if it's
actually someone else or it's a month
later and we've put you know the time
you've written it you kind of know how
it works when you come back a month
later and you look at your immaculately
documented code and the pure logical
arrangement of the whole thing maybe it
turns out you can't quite remember quite
as well exactly what all the magic you
have to do in order to use the software
correctly is even just at the level of
what's which to use or what order the
parameters go or whatever so and when
that happens we call those areas a
process because we like this error of
theme and then if that goes okay or even
if it doesn't go okay we then you know
run our process and it produces the
results of our analysis it produces an
analytical result and a subtler thing
can can go wrong there which is that
there can be
mismatch between the data that we're now
feeding into the system and the data
that we originally developed it with so
basically the assumption we're always
making assumptions when we about the
domain and the data when we build some
kind of analyst of course we have some
idea of what what the data is going to
mean and that's not a flaw in our
analysis analysis can't work if we don't
make any assumptions about about the
data and about the domain but if if the
data that we develop it on is very
different in some way from the data that
we end up running it on we can end up
with an invalid model or an invalid
calculation or at least a model that's
not going to work well because you know
I mean a classic example of this is
credit scoring where you build a model
on one population then over time you
start using it to score a different
population you know historically an
example was most credit models were
built on men and then when banks started
lending to women they haven't they
haven't you know the models weren't
built on a female population so
potentially their characteristics were
very different can be anything like this
just a difference in the distribution of
the data that's coming in and so if that
happens then potentially everything's
working correctly in it the algorithms
are working correctly the models doing
what it's supposed to do it's just that
now we have much less confidence than
the outputs and we call those errors of
applicability and then the final thing
and in some sense the worst thing of all
is at the end of it we have to interpret
the analytical results and we can get
that wrong too we can misunderstand what
it is so if we code the model hopefully
we understand what it means with and
this can be you know this cannot be a
subtle thing at all this can be an
incredibly fundamental thing like you
know we have a thing yeah and we have
some systems say where it's safe for an
aeroplane to to take off and it comes
out with 99.9 percent and you think
fantastic 99.9 percent good to go and
what 99.9 percent actually means is 99
percent chance the aeroplane will crash
if you take off I mean it can be as
basic as this you can get the model
wrong where this happens all the time
you see this with targeting it's
incredibly common that you build a model
to rank a set of customers for who are
the best targets and then you start from
the wrong end of the list and target all
your worst prospects it's incredibly
easy to sue and again that's a different
kind of error
interpretation thereof interpretation at
the output and it's only if you get
through all these stages successfully
that you end up with a successful opera
operationalization of your model the
first time you put more data through now
if you buy in for this process tool you
have to buy into the detail you have to
buy into you know any of it particular
but if your analyses processes look
anything like this at all what I think
is incredibly sobering is to put some
numbers on it now I've just made up
these numbers these aren't even measured
numbers these are just my these are the
most optimistic numbers I feel it's
possible to put on this process for
anyone I've ever seen doing this oh
actually that's not very optimistic
because there are no numbers so I reckon
you're doing pretty well if 80% of the
time you don't fundamentally
misunderstand something at the start
maybe you're better than that maybe you
can do it 90% of time maybe you can do
it 99% of the time me I think 80% is
pretty good not making an important bug
an important mistake a meaningful you
know not not just some trivial one that
gets a decimal point wrong but a
fundamental bug encoding I think 70% is
incredibly optimistic for that again
maybe I'm just bad at this stuff but you
know run the analytical process let's
assume that you only screw that up 10
percent of the time that your data
hasn't changed fundamentally 80 percent
of the time and that you don't
misinterpret the results from 90% of the
time anyone think these are ridiculously
pessimistic numbers anyone much better
than this in the room don't be shy you
think they're optimistic yeah I think
they might be optimistic
like I said you don't real numbers these
are like my upper bound on what I think
you could reasonably expect well the bad
news is if you do that the first time
through the process when you run it
you've only got a 36 percent chance of
getting a right answer and again I don't
mean it's going to be out in the fifth
decimal place I mean like it might be
completely invalid the bad news is every
time you go around this cycle you don't
redevelop it but you do run new data so
you get to use the software again you
get the chance for your data to have
drifted again and you get the chance to
misinterpret it again so if you haven't
built this into a pipeline then
each time through potential Easter and
of course it doesn't drop down
mechanically like this but it does drop
down each time so this is the this is
sort of sobering backdrop to why I think
maybe some of this TDD a stops a good
idea bad news is that I'm not going to
tell you how to eliminate all these
sources of errors or whatever I'm just
going to give you some tools that I hope
help you think about how to do it and
some tools that actually help with at
least some parts of this process ok so
there are between two and two and a half
main ideas actually implemented in the
TDD a library that we're going to be
playing about with the first idea is the
idea of a reference s and the second one
is the idea of constraints and we're
going to go through these in some detail
but very briefly the idea with reference
tests please for those of you who know
about test-driven development they're a
bit like system and integration tests so
the idea is that when we've developed an
analytical process of whatever kind we
capture some kind of a test that we can
run to check that it's working correctly
and then we rerun that periodically like
before we do before we use that process
again we check that the tests still
passing but nothing is broken and we
rerun these in fact we rerun these tests
all the time basically whenever we go to
a new platform whenever we don't go to a
new platform whenever we run it on some
new data whenever night turns to day or
day turns tonight we run these tests and
you might think if you haven't changed
your software you know how could it
possibly fail when it was working before
but those of you who've done this stuff
will realize that that there are there
are a thousand reasons why things that
work today end up not working tomorrow
whether it's because you upgraded your
operating system or you changed your
version of Python or you change one of
your libraries or the operating system
upgraded the operating system or your
helpful colleague upgrading an operating
system or there's a way to k bargain
we've just tripped over a day or a
daylight saving times bug or you know
actually there's this corruption and
your data change well there's this
corruption in your code change and there
are a million reasons why these things
not and that's before you even take it
to a different platform you know you
developed it on a Mac and now you're
going to run it on Linux we developed a
linux and now you're going to run out on
Windows all of these things can cause
things that work in one place not to
work anymore so it's incredibly useful
to have tests that check this so that's
the first idea the library has
lots of support for writing the kinds of
tests that I think are useful in in in
testing analytical processes and the
second idea is the idea of constraint
discovery and verification and these
things are a bit like unit tests for
data again for those we've know about TD
so this is the idea of checking that
your inputs are the right kinds of
inputs that your outputs or the right
kind of outputs and if you have
intermediate so that your intermediates
are the right kinds of intermediates
using constraint technology and we'll
talk about all of this in in much more
detail and I said two and a half ideas
the third idea not fully it's sort of
implement in the library but not in the
constraint bit is some fancy stuff for
characterizing strings with the
automatic discovered regular expressions
but we'll come to that so if you haven't
done it you need to have the TDD a
library and you can get if you're on
Wi-Fi and you haven't got it you can get
that in one of two ways you can either
just pip install TDD a or you if you
want the source which you're of course
welcome to do you can clone it using
that git clone command my contention is
that we've done detailed testing to
establish that it runs under Python 2
and python 3 on Macs on Linux on Windows
and under both unit tests and PI test it
might be the case that not all of those
things turned out to be true when we've
tried it earlier this week but I believe
it's all true now that it's MIT license
so you can use it for pretty much
anything there is Swink source
documentation in the doc subdirectory of
the source release there's also a built
copy online at Python hosted org slash
TDD a and there's a quick reference
guide which some of you have to the two
main parts the reference testing part in
the constraint generation part here but
also available at that URL there handily
the printed version of the of the cheat
sheet has the documentation link wrong
it's it's actually right in the link but
it's difficult to click the link it
turns out on a bit of paper so but it's
updated online has anyone not got the
TDD library
I'm in Italy together and obviously if
you are not in a position to type but
you want to buddy up with someone who's
got a computer that would be a good
thing to do as well I think I'm just
going to carry on okay so reference s
let's go through that in slightly more
detail so the idea with reference
testing is you already have when you're
doing some analysis you already have
some process for deciding when you're
done right it might not be a formal
process but you do something you come up
with a result you don't believe it you
go around you keep working on it till
you've got something you're happy with
them um what what I mean by done could
be you decide to show it to a colleague
you decide to ship it you decide to you
know commit it you decide to believe it
get someone else to believe it whatever
but you have some process by which you
write you know either determine it's not
going to work and you stop or you have
some level of belief in it you're going
to start using it in some way you're
going to give it to someone so let's not
change any of that not talking about
writing tests first or any of that
property do test-driven development
stuff like that all I'm talking about is
you've got some process what you should
what I'm recommending that you do is
this you developed it on some data
capture that input data preferably in
source control or at least put it
somewhere where you know where it is and
it's not going to get lost
capture the output data the results that
were produced even if that result is you
know like an ASCII file or a PDF or
something capture that output and
preferably capture the analytical
process of the whole things in software
and you can just run it mechanically and
you can set it up so that it reads your
known inputs runs itself and produces
the output if you can't do that at the
very least write down a detailed list of
instructions for exactly how to do that
and that is your first test that is your
reference test so the word reference
just I don't know it doesn't really mean
anything it's just just what we call it
internally but it's it's the idea of
this is our reference whereby we'll know
whether things working at least on the
stuff we developed it on originally okay
so act as a reference for where the
stuff is working
and then the idea as I say is that you
just rerun this thing periodically and
ideally you have some kind of an
automated procedure for checking whether
the results the same so some kind of a
diff tool or whatever if you haven't got
an automatic procedure for doing that if
it is producing a PDF that you can't
diff whatever reason you know then you
have to be the tool you have to look at
it and say is this the same result and
it could be a single number you know it
could be that all of this stuff takes
this enormous amount of data and it's
supposed to produce oh I don't know
forty two or twenty three point four or
zebra or something or it could be
something something bigger than that
whatever it is capture it and run that's
your test so that's the idea of a
reference test there I'm clear what I
mean by reference has any confusion any
questions any yeah and you can do it you
can do it for sub bits of the analysis
obviously and it might be better to do
it earlier but what as a sort of minimal
thing what I'm saying is you already
have a process for you know deciding one
stop just don't quite stop then just
spend the extra little bit of time to
save all your input save away your
outputs write some instructions if
necessary for how to run it again and
then do that preferably automatically
but if not automatically at least before
you before you run it again check it
still works on the old thing and
produces the same valid result I mean
sooner is better doing it really early
on is really good but that's hard
everyone finds it hard to do it early so
let's let's not shoot for them let's
just do the basics did you this little
B's versioning your models no no well
it's so you mean the capturing of this
stuff
yeah the capturing of it obviously if
you then change it because that's
another way things break people fix bugs
you would not believe how dangerous
fixing bugs is yeah obviously if you
change it then you know ideally all this
stuff should go into version control or
at least the code should go into version
control and certainly you should be
versioning it so that if the right
answer now changes so a common thing
would be you develop it you think you've
got the right answer but you know
eventually you discover either in some
very embarrassing way or in some nice
way that actually the answer is not
right and so you fix something and you
change it it's of course a good idea to
have that version
to update your reference results at that
point and so forth yes yeah well if
they're really large then you probably
can't you be probably don't want to take
them in version control one thing to do
obviously is if you can to use cut-down
versions of them so often even if the
real thing you developed it on was you
know terabytes of data you cannot often
still form a useful reference test out
of some subset of that if that's not
possible then I guess the thing I'd
recommend is that you at least take some
kind of check some of the things put
that in version control and then you
know have your your reference test be
that you first of all check that the
checksum is correct on the input data
and that your checksum is correct on the
output data and then you know that
you're you know you're checking the
right thing you can check that so if you
like turn the whole thing into it into a
checksum basically yep so this is this
is more like a integration or a system
test than a than a unit test but I mean
the whole idea is to take this stuff the
point is not that this is different the
point is that this isn't typically done
in analysis whereas it is often done in
on software side the next part of it the
constraint that was open that is very
different for anything in in test-driven
development but this part of it is it is
it's just take it's you know I'm not
thinking of anything clever about it
it's just the goal was right to take
these good ideas from best development
practice and apply them to data analysis
now the library does have a whole load
of things that are that make it much
more suitable for analytical type tests
than traditional type because it turns
out that you know typically when we're
testing all the reefs off 28 or a couple
of numbers are right or something
whereas here we might be checking at an
entire data frames right or but you know
a graphs right or something you can't
really use the same techniques for that
which is what the library helps with
okay so in fact that's exactly what this
is out so the library the reference test
part of a library has support amongst
other things for comparing an actual
string one that you've got in memories
you've generated from some process to an
expected string that's that's in a file
right simple stuff
it also has support for doing things
excluding lines with that contained
particular substring so it's or regular
expressions so it's very common for
example that if you produce well almost
anything but particularly a graph say it
might have a date in it it might have a
version number in it and those things
don't make the graph different in any
meaningful way so you don't want a test
to fail just because it's got a
different version number in it or
because it was produced on a different
date so you need this ability to exclude
bits and pieces and it supports that in
fact it has a more general ability to
pre-process the output in just you just
provide a function to manipulate it in
whatever way which could be stripping
out bits of it or modifying bits of it
or standardizing bits of it or commuting
bits of it it has support for writing
out when a test fails for writing out
the actual result which was just sitting
there in memory into a file so that you
can now dip it against your expected
phone it will tell you what the
difficulty to run is it has the ability
to check multiple files rather than a
single file or indeed files rather than
strings and it has the ability also to
automatically regenerate your reference
outputs for you so once you've verified
that you have fixed a bug and so the
correct output is now different it can
rewrite that standard output for you and
this sounds very trivial it turns out to
be very useful in practice now you have
the responsibility for actually checking
that the new output is the output that
you want if you just use this blindly
obviously the whole thing will turn to
[ __ ] very quickly to use the technical
term so this is for unstructured data
the stuff for structured data like data
frames and things as well but this is
the first part we're going to look at so
actually at the point we if you don't
have a view or don't know about PI test
just use unit tests because you want to
have PI test installed if you prefer PI
tests there are PI test variants of all
the stuff here as well so the first
thing you need to do is and as you want
to try it in your own day so the first
thing to do is to get this so if you've
got the TDD a library installed go to
somewhere that you have to write stuff
so a temp directory or just somewhere
you're happy to do stuff
and if you run the command Python - M
TDD a dot reference test examples that
will copy into the directory you're in a
copy of the test data and the test
script in a fire in a directory it will
create called reference test examples so
Python - M is just saying run the module
PD a dot reference test examples so that
would be a really good thing to do I can
obviously do this as well I'll maybe do
it after after people - how to go
themselves seasoned see what should have
happened because obviously it works on
my machine at least it did earlier and
then when you've done that the first
thing to do is to look at the two
results so we've got a thing called
generators pi which generates two
different HTML files one of which is
called string result that HTML and the
other is called file result that HTML so
the first thing to do is just to look at
those maybe open them in a browser or
something like that or look at the
actual HTML file they're both just
single files and then the first thing is
- so there is a test already written if
I there are two versions of it there's a
unit test version of pi test version in
the unit test subdirectory there's one
called test using reference tasks API
and it's probably called the same thing
in the PI test directory but it's set up
for PI tests anyway you should just be
able to run those commands and you
should get some passing tests with I
think five tests that pass
I was going to say I'll do it at the
same time but I guess then I'd then that
wouldn't be productive so I'll undo that
I'll do it afterwards so maybe when
someone succeeded in doing that getting
tests passing you could shout bingo or
whatever and and if no point in hoeing
succeeds in making the test pass this
tutorials going very badly indeed it's
working okay and have you looked at the
you should probably look at the HTML
probably in a text editor but you can
also look at it in the browser it's very
pretty
he says
so what what would all the tests doing
is running this generator code which and
the two tests that are relevant out of
the five are one of them generates the
string result in memory so that's one of
the two webpages in memory and then the
test checks that that's the same as a
firewall at least more or less the same
as a file it turns out this file
includes copyright information and
version information that's not the same
in the generated code in generated page
as in the original one but because we've
passed exclusions in as we'll see those
lines are getting ignored and it's only
checking the meaningful the semantic
differences if you like the other one is
writing out a temporary file into a
temporary directory that system gives it
as file result and again it's checking
that those up to these these rather
trivial changes are correct as well and
so that's what this notes about the fact
that we're we're specifically ignoring
with outside patents we probably should
have said strings but we're ignoring
lines with copyright and lines with the
provision in we could have been more
specific
okay I think because we don't have that
much time or people happy if I move on
to the next bit now so the idea now is
that we want to invalidate the test so
what we're going to do is we want to
make some change to the generator code
so that the files that get produced are
different so if you look in generators
PI it's a very simple thing that has got
some explicit HTML in it including this
h1 tag and my suggestion is that you
change the contents of that heading one
by turning it to uppercase or something
like that just making it different so
that so that we get a different result
out of the code so literally open up
generators dot PI in your favorite text
editor or IDE or whatever and make some
change to the string so going to
completely show you this now sorry is it
more used to foley maybe it's more
useful I leave it up
so literally just you know make the
title add your name to it or capitalize
it or change some other bit of it or
something so that so that we're going to
get the wrong result Robin Wright
released a different result of them I
understand you could unplug you eat
there is one left actually okay and then
whether you use PI test or unit test
just run the test again you should get
either one or two failures I think if
you change both both the headings you
should get two phases I guess we're
going to change one of them it'll
probably only get one so it should fail
and it should fail in a fairly helpful
waiver that tells you if you look at the
output first of all what the difference
is and secondly perhaps even more
importantly what the diff command is
hopefully localized for your system so
if you're on Windows hopefully it will
give you a file comparison command and
if you on the next or Mac it will give
you a diff command to actually look at
the differences and then if you run that
diff command you should be able to see
first of all the changes that you've
made to the files or the strings but
secondly you'll also notice the
different versions and the different
copyright emphasizing that that those
were different originally because you
haven't changed those yeah
yeah they're testing exactly the same
thing it's just one of them obviously
the way PI testing unit I mean you can
use unit test tests under PI test but PI
test people tend to hate that because
unit test evil apparently for reasons I
don't understand but yeah they're
testing exactly the same thing sorry
because of people succeeded with that
you've got failures excellent so the
idea is now that let's suppose that this
change that you've made is is is an
improvement not much of an analytical
process but our analytical process of
writing a webpage to fixed webpage let's
assume that this is the correct output
that we now want the old stuff was wrong
or at least we've decided we want the
new stuff and now we'd like to rewrite
our reference output so that when we
generate this we get the right the right
result the way you do that is by running
again depending whether using unit tests
or PI tests in the case of PI test you
just add a minus capital W to the line
that you use to run the tests or you can
say minus minus right all and in case PI
test you add minus - right - all minus s
and what that will do is that will take
the generated output from the test write
that into the area where the reference
results files are and what that means if
you after having done that mine that run
it with right or or - W and then run it
again without the write all or - W your
test should now pass with your modified
code and again I can't emphasize enough
obviously if you blindly do that
whenever the tests fail you just use -
write all all you're going to do is
gradually gradually write bugs into into
your testing process but if you take the
responsibility to actually check that it
really is the correct result that you
want then then this saves a huge amount
of time and effort and in fact reduces
chances of getting things wrong because
whole thing's automated rather than you
depending on actual copying files into
place and so on
okay hopefully that's incredibly
inspiring and you're all going to go off
and do this with your with your
instruction output I will talk through
briefly the same thing for in it
I'm sure the title for that so I didn't
used to be if only go so that's that
final bit just just journey again to
check in on class okay so we have
exactly comparable things for structured
data a not just for generating a blob of
text but for generating either the two
specific examples this supports are a
data frame or a CSV file now CSV files
obviously you've got all the problems
about CSV file formats and so on but it
will read a lot of CSV files sensibly
you might have to make some changes if
you have a weird CSV format so with
structured data the equivalent stuff is
we want to be able to so what the
library supports is comparing a
generated data frame or CSV file to a
reference data frame that you've got or
a reference CSV file again it will show
you the specific difficulty to use to
see what the difference is if they're
not the same in the case of the files
you can check multiple CSVs at the same
time and it will show you all the errors
not just the first one you can specify a
subset of columns to check so it may be
that there are some columns that have
got random numbers in it or B you're not
expected examine what you don't care
about you can choose whether you want it
to be very picky about types or not
generally being very picky about types
with pandas is is not fantastic in my
experience but you can be you can choose
whether you care about column order so
if if the thing that you're testing has
two columns in a different order do you
regard that as a problem or not it's up
to you you can choose to ignore the
actual data values and only focus on the
types you can choose the precision
floating point comparisons and again
it's got the automatic rewriting behave
you know obviously I'm not all this is
documented in the in the full
documentation we're also not going to go
through all these variants and in fact I
think given time I mean these are the
four calls that you need again these
slides are available
there is a comparable exercise you can
do I mean it's it's very similar we can
if you succeeded with the other one you
could do it very quickly it's just two
so you've already got this data if you
go into the reference subdirectory you
should see data frame result dot HTML I
think that's dot CSV not dot HTML yep
it's amazing so you can you can come and
talk about testing and getting things
correct illustrate the impossibility of
it by your own incompetence okay sorry
about that I'll update the slides
afterwards I mean that good online copy
of the slides afterwards um so this is
this is tiny date frame that's being
generated again you can run it and and
it should pass you can look at the data
frame burning that little command and so
the idea here is it generates a bunch of
things including a I'm sorry a string
column called s and the string column
called S writes one of the
floating-point numbers out to a fixed
number of decimal places and you can
specify those that there's a precision
parameter in the data frames function or
the data frames file that specifies how
many places to write it out to so if you
change that default behavior obviously
you'll get a different string column
which means that the test will fail so
if you do that if you change the if you
open up data frames dot pi and change
that default precision from three to two
or three seven or whatever it should the
test should start failing three tests
should fail because the same same
function is used to generate three
different data for three different tests
and then again if you do the - - right
or - s in case of PI test or the minus
capital W in the case of unit test it
will rewrite those reference results for
you and everything will be good so again
because times short I think I won't give
you a lot of time to do that but you get
the idea basically this thing supports
both structured data and unstructured
data in the fullness of time maybe it'll
support JSON and other things as well
but at the moment that's the that's the
basic scope of the thing and it's we've
found it incredibly helpful we use this
this all time as an augmentation of
unit test what I test yes you can do
what you like
No so the I mean you have the option of
just pickling moments during or in fact
we also have support for storing them as
feather files for those of you know
about feather so feather is a library
written by Wes McKinney and Hadley
Wickham is one of the are stars that
allows data to be data frames to be
shared between our or persisted to disk
and written from and read by both pandas
and our including type information and
so forth so that's another good way of
doing it no I mean obviously CSV is is
the worst possible thing to use it's
just that it's incredibly common so we
support but no you're much much better
either pickling it or we use and feather
or something like that okay let's move
on I'm talk about constraints yes no but
if you wanted to add support for hdf5
into a pull request that would be
awesome
okay constraint generation and
verification so constraints so hopefully
you'll agree that it's fairly common for
data analysis to use data tables in some
way you know data frames whatever you
want to call them tabular data with like
columns that have meaning and types and
rows little different values either as
inputs or as outputs or as intermediates
or or all of those things certainly a
lot of the analysis we do is like that
there are obviously other things like
you know JSON XML and binary data and so
forth but this is this is incredibly
common and there are probably lots of
things that we know ought to be true
about that data and so what we could do
in principle is we could write down all
the things that we think ought to
feature about that data and we could
check them
and the only problem with that is no one
can be bothered i certain can't be
bothered and if I did I wouldn't think
of most of the things and I'd probably
get them wrong
life's too short so the big idea with
the constraint stuff is instead of us
writing down the stuff let's get the
computer to figure out what constraints
are true about one or more specific data
sets that we use and these can be input
data sets these can be output data set
so they can be off and ideally it should
be all we should be doing this at all
stages through the analysis let it write
out a set of constraints that were true
of the data we we built the process on
and then check whether they're true so
we have a what we call a discovery phase
we're given some data sets it writes a
set of constraints to it write them out
as a JSON file and then a verification
procedure that checks that some
potentially different typically
different data obeys those constraints
as well now of course the constraints
won't always be obeyed by the next set
of data because no two data sets are the
same but the idea is even though none of
us almost none of us can be bothered to
write down a whole load of constraints
maybe we're willing to look at the two
or three things that fail next time we
run it because you know customer number
is now bigger or date is you know the
biggest date in the dataset is now
bigger than it used to be well do the
dates later of course the dates because
so maybe that wasn't a good constraint
to write in so maybe we still don't want
the date to be you know further ahead
than twenty fifty or twenty five hundred
or something or the day after tomorrow
or indeed today maybe we don't want it
to be bigger than today's date whatever
today's date is a variable date and so
that's that's really big idea so let's
look at some examples of this so here
are some example constraints that might
be true if we have an age field probably
we'd be suspicious of ages more than
hundred fifty notwithstanding the guy
who died the other day who was Perry
hundred fifty five I think it was but no
birth certificate to prove it
we might want the type of our age to be
an integer or at least to be a number if
we've got a customer ID we might not
allow that to be null at least in a
master customer table we might want in
our master customer table or customer
IDs to be unique I never have any
duplicates of those things
we've got a credit card number we might
want to have 16 digits and so on and so
forth so constraint on single fields we
might also have constraints on whole
data sets and maybe the data set should
contain a field called
CID and maybe it should have a
particular number of Records it should
have exactly hundred eighteen records
for example maybe if we've got tagging
on fields and things one of the fields
should be tagged with an O and may be
exactly one of the fields should be
tagged with an ax maybe it should be
sorted in date order on some date field
and then I also be multi field
constraint so if we've got a start date
and an end date
maybe the start date is not supposed to
be later than the end date that would be
quite a sensible thing maybe if we have
things representing force and mass and
acceleration we believe Newton knew what
he was talking about then pretty much
Airport to equal MA since that's a
universal law outside the quantum and
relativistic scopes you know lots are
lots and lots of stuff like this but we
could write down so the kinds of
constraints currently supported by the
TDD a library are minimum values maximum
values signs as well now obviously the
sign of a number is fully captured by
the minimum the maximum but we think
sign is so significant that even if you
end up with a smaller minimum than
before it's probably significant if it's
negative where it wasn't before so we
separately capture constraints about the
sign we look at whether a field is null
or not we actually capture it as the
maximum number of nulls allowed in a
column but typically that's either
either 0 or all the constraints not
there in other words what you're really
saying is this is not an honorable field
we detect whether there are duplicates
in fields I repeated values particularly
for string fields but the numeric fields
as well in the case of strings we
calculate the minimum string length and
maximum string lengths I've missed one
out we also for categorical looking
fields with not very many different
string values we capture the list of
values that are allowed and although
it's not implemented on the master
branch we also have an ability to
generate regular expressions to
characterize fields and use those for
verification that's the Rex PI thing
talk about at the end if we don't run
out of time it is included in the
library and it is available online but
it's not it's not used right now for
this discovery and verification process
but when we release version not point
four of the library which might be
within the next few days that will
become available not all the constraints
apply to all field types but column
types but many of them do so we have a
similar sort of exercise we can go
through so again if you go to some area
where you are happy to write new
directory your temp directory or
whatever and you run Python - MTD a
constraint examples that will copy a
directory called constraints examples
into your directory and that will
include - CSV files containing one
called elements 92 which contains
information from Wikipedia about the
first 92 elements in the periodic table
that is everything up to uranium and
also elements 1 1 8 dot CSV which
contains information about the first
hundred 18 elements of the periodic
table which is all of them that have
numbers a few years ago I think I think
we might be up 220 of now but they're
pretty uninteresting and then you go
into that directory so you should see in
that directory as I say elements and
linked to dot CSV no it's probably in
it's either there in a subdirectory I
think my actually in test data and if
you run Python elements discover ninety
two dot pi or I know that's the other
thing when you install the TDD a library
as well as installing installing like
library itself it installs a TDD a
command for you that you can use and so
this TDD a contract the simple thing to
don't think i'd recommend that you do is
actually run the second command there
TDD a discover test dataset slash
elements ninety two dot CSV elements
ninety two dot C to do what that will do
is it will run its discovery process
over the first ninety-two element
the periodic table read them into a data
frame using CS the CSV reader it will
then generate a set of constraints based
on the first 92 elements and it will
write them out as a JSON file called
Alan's 92 dot t-- d da and it will look
like that so this is saying zed which is
the atomic number is an integer field it
has a minimum value of 1 and the maximum
value of 92 it's always positive it
doesn't have any Knolls and it doesn't
have any duplicates which of course you
should read as this field has to be an
integer field the smallest value it's
allowed is 1 the largest value that's
allowed is 92 it must always be positive
it mustn't have any nails and it must
not have any duplicates and so on and so
on down so you see there are various
other things we've got some string ones
with for example the allowed value for
chemical series it noticed there weren't
very many different ones so it's
actually listed those out and so on and
so forth so have people succeeded in
running that and getting that elements
92 generated know as anyone succeeded in
running it ah missing imports
feather ah feather you have to install
yes you probably have to pip install
feather format sorry about that
ah Wow
[ __ ] testing you see that's the great
thing about having a whole lot of people
in a room to test yourself both we
apologies yes it is it difference aw
feather - format yeah sorry about that
I will type that on the slide that
should be a conditional import of course
but apparently it's not okay that'll
make that work sure okay in it so if you
have a look at it you see that Jason so
now the interesting thing to do is to
where you so the first thing is to
verify that the data set you generated
those constraints from satisfies it by
running the TDD a verify command so
again I'd recommend the second on this
TDD a verified test data slash elements
ninety two dot CSV elements ninety two
dot TDI verify the very same CSV file
that you generated the constraints from
with those constraints and match it
obviously pass you should get I forget
one number 67 or seventy two passes or
something some number of passes no fails
is the important thing now I think
that's what I get I get seventy two
classes when I run that and obviously
the ticks are the passes and the crosses
of the fails nightly fails so that's
good so now we can try and use those
same constraints to see whether the full
data set the 418 elements how display
the constraints as well and what we
expect is they won't because after all
one of the constraints that got
generated was the atomic number
shouldn't be bigger than 92 and of
course in 101st 1819 elements of course
it is bigger than 92 it goes up to 118
so if you run exactly the same verify
command but now using elements 1 1 8 dot
CSV rather than elements 9
rather than elements 92 dot CSV you
should get I think it's five failures so
some of those are still with maximum
minimum values I think some of them are
also to do with nulls there are nulls in
the bigger dataset where there aren't
nulls in some columns in the smaller
data set
and then really all that's left is to
you can you can there's I think included
in the data there's a elements one one
eight dot T V da which I previously
generate but you could generate yourself
if you want to that is the constraints
generate from the larger data set and
what you should find is if you verify
the larger data set against that it
passes but also that if you verify the
ninety-two data set against that large
118 set of constraints those should pass
as well because of course the
constraints that were true for isn't
quite followed but it pretty much
follows that the ones 418 about the
other 92 and indeed they do so I'll give
you a minute or two to do that and then
okay now obviously anyone shout if there
are questions or I guess I'm hoping what
you know clearly it to some extent you
know you're just typing you're not
you're not really doing doing that
interesting stuff it but I hope what
you're getting is the idea that these
constraints are useful and that if you
yes you'll have to edit them you have to
edit that JSON file and either change
them by hand sometimes or delete them
when they're not relevant but the idea
is if you have a process that you run
every day and you first will generate
the constraints the first time you look
at them maybe you take out the ones that
don't look sensible or you modify the
ones that don't look sensible then every
time you run it you see whether there
are failures if there are failures you
look at whether the failures you care
about indicate there's actually wrong
with your input data or your output data
or your intermediates or you or you
discover that actually that's that's
perfectly fine that's constraint which
shouldn't have been there and then
either you modify the constraint or you
remove the constraint you end up with a
very useful set of constraints and you
can make those even more useful by
generating extra check columns that are
exactly things that you you put in
specifically to check that they you know
because they should be true they are
true so for example if you have a set of
fields that are supposed to sum to
another field or you have a set of
intermediate results that are supposed
to sum to to a grand total maybe you
want to put the intermediates in and
check that those things are true or you
know or explicitly put in a difference
called make sure that that column is
always zero and stuff like
those can be very powerful ways of
implementing other data sanity checks
that you might want to do within this
same context let's think just by writing
actual columns into the day so that
represent things that you know either
should always be won or still be 0
always true or always false or you know
never longer than 10 digits or whatever
it happens to be okay
so we've done quite well on timing
because that was what I figured we might
get done that might just mean of course
that I rushed through it far too quickly
and you're all completely bamboozled but
it does at least mean we could talk a
little bit about Rex I think is quite
exciting so let's talk about that brief
here's an example of a successful
verification with failures it's an
example unsuccessful verification oh and
here's the other thing you'll all know
because you'll know it happens book if
nothing else appear since the dog in the
night-time so in in silver blaze there's
an interesting part in the book where
Gregory de Scotland Yard detective says
to Holmes is there any other point to
which you wish to draw my attention when
Holmes says to the Curious Incident of
the dog in the night-time and Gregory
says inspector Gregory says the dog did
nothing in the nighttime and the home
says ah that was the Curious Incident
and of course what that proved as you're
instantly of recognizes that the
perpetrator was obviously known to the
dog and therefore the dog didn't bark
because it was a known perpetrator and
that proved that the butler did it or
whatever it was when you generate these
constraints it's very tempting to look
at the constraints and say do these make
sense but it's very important to look
for the constraints that don't get
generated as well so you know you have a
field that shouldn't be null and it
doesn't generate the constraint that
says it shouldn't be null well that
means you've got nulls in that field
you generate a field that should be
unique for every record and it doesn't
generate a constraint that says it's
unique for every record that's telling
you that you've got duplicates I mean
none of these hard things to find anyway
but again this is a very easy mechanism
for producing these things and as you
look through them its input units the
figure of rounding it's important to
look at what's not there as well as what
is there because very often that's every
bit as significant
okay so let's uh that's the API you can
even look that up in your answer it's
beautiful APM that's oh the other thing
is the when you do a verification as
well as just printing textual output it
can produce a data frame with that
verification in it which has one row for
every column and one column for every
constraint type and then they're true
with the constraints pass false if the
constraints fail and none if there was
no constraint to be checked for that
case because either it didn't apply
although there wasn't a useful thing
discovered and obviously you can write
here if you if you really want so you
can write your own TDD a files by hand
wouldn't recommend it but that you can
no no I'm sorry what this is saying is
that when we ran this verification some
particular verification it's saying that
there were two failures for the atomic
weight field and three passes that the
type constraint passed that the min
constraint passed that there wasn't the
min length feel min length constraint
because it's not a string field so you
don't get a min rank constraint that the
max failed so this is probably when we
verified against one one eight and the
max was higher in one one eight dataset
than the other data set there was no max
length constraint again because it's not
a string field the same constraint
passed the max Knowles constraint passed
so that means there were nulls in the
date in in the atomic weight when there
was a constraint saying they weren't
allowed to be and there was no no
duplicates constraint and know about
values constraints that make sense it
can be a little bit confusing but true
true means the constraint passed false
means the constraint was violated failed
and null or not a number means there
wasn't a constraint to validate
well no it's it's whatever you're
verifying it so this is this is when
when when you run a verify it produces a
verification object that verification
object has a two frame method on it
that two frame method produces a data
frame with one row per per column and a
column for each constraint and it's
whatever it is you could have written
them by hand or they could be from the
discovery process or whatever yeah yes
no there isn't at the moment but that is
obviously an extremely necessary thing
and that is something we will be working
on and if you were to write such a thing
we would love that pull request but we
will do it anyway if you even just put
in a change request against the repo for
that that will encourage us to do it
because it's obviously useful thing yes
so as I mentioned we're a you know we're
a commercial software house and analysis
house as well as this so what we tend to
do is we tend to implement things in our
software first as a sort of
rough-and-ready version that's useful
and then we try and learn all the
lessons of that put it into the nice
open source frame so we have the multi
field constraint stuff in mirror our
software we haven't ported that to thing
yet but that will definitely come to to
this the whole day set constraints we
mostly haven't even gotten mirror at the
moment we have got the regular
expression stuff and say the regular
expression all the basic rate expression
capability that I'm about to talk about
is in the library as well it's just not
actually when that is on a branch in in
the code as well but it's not it's not
tested enough to want to push it here so
that so that will come
so in fact you do futures there you go
though it doesn't include the one you
asked about which is which is important
so the immediate future is your Expo
which is what I'm about to talk about
which is automatically covering regular
expressions to characterise
stringfield's join keys or importance of
multiple data set things where you
should have particular kinds of
relationships between keys in different
columns is a good thing to test as well
there's a very obvious thing that we
haven't really done much work on yet
which is characterizing distributions or
not you know simple mins and maxes and
things but what is the general shape of
this distribution and does it look like
it's you both first-order and mult you
know higher-order things so what's the
one-dimensional shape of this
distribution what's the
multi-dimensional shape of the
distribution that will take a bit longer
nearly constraint discovery one of the
limitations of constraint discovery is
that it's all or nothing if you have a
single negative value it's not going to
generate and should be positive
constraint but it obviously would be
possible to say this constraints very
very nearly true maybe it's supposed to
be true and so that's a thing we look at
there's obviously get more and more json
data in the world so we should maybe
think about that and think about json
schemas as part of that and there are
lots of other things including combining
constraints his first final slide which
gets repeated later because I thought
this might be as far as we'd get but we
haven't been to where explain so who
knows about regular expressions and you
will not know about regular expressions
seriously does everyone know about
regular expressions that's fantastic so
you already know the joke right some
people think you know when they have a
problem I know I'll use regular
expressions now they have two problems
regular expressions incredibly powerful
you all know what they are so I'm not
going to talk it through they're a
complete pain to write but they're very
good and they're you know clearly given
a bunch of string data it would be nice
if something could come up with the
regular expression or regular
expressions that characterize that
accurately for you and that's what Rex
PI is all about I should emphasize it's
not intended to do completely general
text I mean it will work on completely
general text but it's it's intended for
the sort of text that you typically get
in string data in structured data sets
so
you know it's string identifies and
things with obvious structure it's not
trying to write regular expressions for
English language or Hungarian language
or you know random crap it's it's stuff
with some structure in that it's that
it's trying to find so you know
telephone numbers and post codes and zip
codes and you know the sort of stuff
that you actually you actually like to
find so you know pros and cons of
regular expressions well obviously
they've got the pro of being powerful
and - the ubiquitous and the corn of
being ugly and hard to write and even
harder to read and even harder to debug
and unbelievably hard to quote and
escape that at least in Python we have
our strings which if you don't know
about them you should absolutely use
when using regular expressions because
they make dealing with the backslash is
a lot easier some of you will have seen
verbal expressions which were a craze
about two or three years ago where
everyone was trying to get away from
writing literal regular expressions by
using constructors like this within the
space of about three months they got
written for every language Under the Sun
I have never seen one used in my whole
life in reality we all just write
regular expressions so why not let the
computer do the work so Rex PI is it's
an early attempt it's far from perfect
it's entirely heuristic but it's the
thing that you give it a bunch of
strings and it will return one or more
regular expressions that characterize
those strings it's not it's not
particularly good at collapsing multiple
ones down at one I mean it could do it
mechanically with alternation but it's
not necessary particularly good at
really seeing you know this one's that
one with just a bit more on the end but
we'll get better at that um so there's
an online tool at Rex PI dot Arauco app
comm that lets you paste in a load of
strings on the left and get your regular
expressions out on the right you have
you can choose whether or not it anchors
them a whether it puts a an R power at
the start and a dollar at the end and it
will also you also have the option of
getting it puts capture groups in either
the parentheses to let you pull out the
individual bits and what it does is it
puts capture groups around all the bits
that are variable in the string it
doesn't bother
in a bit aren't variable that adjuster
just a common thing so I orbit you might
reasonably want to pull out so it's
available online it's got a limit of I
don't know housing or 10,000 records or
something just so you kill a silver but
it's also available as part of TDD a
library this is the help for it so
there's a rec sky command that you
should have available so if you
literally if you've got the library if
you just type recs by and then type in
three or four strings that have got some
structure it should spit out one or more
regular expressions that characterize
those strings and my contention is that
it will always produce the right answer
at least a correct answer but it won't
necessarily produce an optimal answer
that's not even trying to produce an
optimal answer it's entirely heuristic
so there's command line version there's
also obviously an API for generating
this there are various options you can
put in to say whether it should in a
what extry with underscores more
actually with dots and things like that
and to say whether you want to capture
groups and whether you want the anchors
and there's a pretty simple API for
using it so there are there so yeah if
you do the same thing if you do the
example thing for your Python - MTD do
don't wreck spider examples again it
will produce it or actually for you
called probably react spy - examples and
there are simple programs in there for
again just with trivial number strings
but it works with with quite big sets of
strings as well it will also work with
string columns and data frame so you
just give it a column from a data frame
and it will work directly from that and
so very soon it will use that for the
constrain generation and the constraint
validation as well and oh that's an
example of doing it to get in pandas
again I think reading this on the slides
probably not very interesting and I'll
do because it's pretty hot in here I'm
happy to take that things I have to look
at examples I would encourage you all to
try this stuff we find it's incredibly
helpful for getting better
of you now solve all three of the bits
by all means come back to me with any
feedback directly as a blogger TD ADA in
further talks about development of this
there's the source code on github do log
bugs do log change requests to pull
requests if you want there's a slack
group that if you tweet me or email me
I'll add you to incredibly quiet you
won't get bombarded weeks can go by
without anyone saying hang on the slack
group but then sometimes there is
there's treasure account where we tweet
about all this [ __ ] and the slightly
buggy version of the slides that we
started with are online at that URL but
within an hour I will have pushed the
slightly corrected and enhanced versions
to that same URL thank you very much all
for coming I really appreciate I hope
you all got something out of it I really
think this stuff is I really think that
stuff is useful we do do it for real it
has helped as it has helped our clients
I think it will help you if you do it as
well unless of course either you're
infallible in which case you don't need
it or you already do all this stuff
anyway in which case I don't know why
you're bothered coming thank you very
much
[Applause]
you
[Music]